salut c'est que j'espère que vous allez
bien alors dans les prochaines semaines
on va décrypter le programme de tous les
candidats à l'élection présidentielle
aujourd'hui on se retrouve donc pour
décrypter le programme de jean luc
mélenchon en dix mesures l'idée étant dû
voir concrètement plus clair sur son
programme au passage je le dirai dans
chaque vidéo de ce type évidemment je
vais pas vous présenter toutes les
mesures en détail là on va vraiment à
l'essentiel mais du coup n'hésitez pas à
découvrir le programme des candidats en
descriptions ou alors à découvrir aussi
mes interviews des candidats à
l'élection présidentielle qui vont
sortir dans les prochaines semaines
directement sur cette chaîne youtube
alors d'abord petite présentation comme
pour tous les candidats qui est donc
jean luc mélenchon il a 70 ans il a fait
des études de lettres et de philosophie
dans le jura est celui la politique
c'est venu très très tôt il se lance
très jeune à gauche au sein du parti
socialiste en 1986 il devient le plus
jeune sénateur de france à seulement 35
ans et puis il a été aussi ministre
délégué à la formation professionnelle
sous le gouvernement jospin entre 2000
et 2002 en 2008 un peu plus tardivement
donc il quitte le parti socialiste
puisqu'il trouve que le parti n'est plus
assez à gauche il fonde à ce moment-là
son propre parti le parti de gauche qui
est devenu aujourd'hui un mouvement la
france insoumise il est aujourd'hui
député de marseille depuis 2010 est il
est notamment connu pour ses
interventions à l'assemblée nationale et
ses qualités d'orateur c'est en
l'occurrence la troisième candidature de
jean-luc mélenchon et par rapport à la
présidentielle de 2017 il ya des points
communs mais aussi des nouveautés dans
son programme et donc je vais vous
expliquer tout ça avec ses dix mesures
majeures première mesure en économie
jean luc mélenchon souhaite augmenter le
smic donc le salaire minimum pour qu'il
atteigne 1400 euros net par mois contre
1200 sont 9 euros nets aujourd'hui en
économie il veut également mettre en
place un salaire maximum autorisé alors
concrètement un salaire maximum autorisé
ça consiste à empêcher que le plus haut
salaire dans une entreprise soit plus de
20 fois supérieur au salaire le plus
faible et enfin dernière mesure
importante particulièrement pour les
jeunes il souhaite verser une allocation
d'autonomie
d'un montant de 1000 63 euros par mois
pour les jeunes de moins de 25 ans ça
concerne en fait les jeunes de moins de
25 ans qui étudie à l'université ou en
lycée professionnel et qui sont
indépendants de leurs parents alors
deuxième mesure jean luc mélenchon veut
mettre en place un service citoyen
obligatoire de neuf mois en fait
concrètement c'est une sorte de service
militaire mais qui n'est pas seulement
axée sur l'aspect militaire en gros la
partie militaire serait optionnelle il y
aurait aussi une formation s'ils pour
par exemple rejoindre et travailler dans
une association ou encore participer à
des projets de défense de
l'environnement ou encore apprendre les
premiers secours et donc potentiellement
beaucoup de choses dans ce service qui
est proposé et le service citoyen serait
pour les femmes et pour les hommes il
serait obligatoire pour tous les jeunes
de moins de 25 ans il durait donc neuf
mois ils seraient payés au salaire
minimum alors troisième mesure on va
parler maintenant d'écologie jean luc
mélenchon souhaite que d'ici 2050 100 %
de l'énergie en france proviennent de
sources d'énergie renouvelable comme par
exemple le solaire ou encore l'éolien
concrètement ça veut dire que jean luc
mélenchon souhaite abandonner certes les
énergies fossiles mais aussi sortir du
nucléaire c'est une mesure qui est
partagé par beaucoup de candidats à
gauche sauf en l'occurrence le
communiste fabien roussel lui ne veut
pas sortir du nucléaire pour la
production d'énergie quatrième promesse
de campagne de jean luc mélenchon s'il
est élu ce qu'il appelle la règle verte
sera inscrite dans la constitution donc
dans la loi suprême du pays en gros il
veut que l'état s'engage à ce qu on ne
prélève pas plus dans la nature que ce
que la nature peut tout simplement
reconstituer et pour s'assurer que cette
règle verte et respectés en france et
que ya pas trop de ressources qui sont
prélevés il veut mettre en place ce
qu'il appelle une planification
écologique
concrètement pour faire très simple
l'objectif c'est de savoir qui produit
quoi et en quelles quantités aujourd'hui
en france autre mesure jean luc
mélenchon propose d'interdire en france
tous les ogm donc ces graines qui sont
modifiés en laboratoire ainsi que tous
les pesticides donc pour faire vraiment
simple tous les produits chimiques
parfois utilisé pour aider les plantes à
pousser ou encore à les protéger des
insectes l'objectif en interdisant tout
ça pour jean luc mélenchon c'est de
limiter les impacts néfastes sur la
santé et sur l'environnement qu'il
pourrait y avoir avec ces produits alors
cinquième point désormais jean luc
mélenchon à un programme qui est
vraiment tourné vers l'espace il veut
que la france participe davantage dans
les programmes de recherche spatiale
notamment pour aller sur mars il milite
pour la création d'une université de
l'espace pour créer donc des emplois
dans le secteur spatial c'est l'un des
rares candidats qu'elle aime à évoquer
autant ce sujet du spatial jean luc
mélenchon estime que la france a sa
place dans ce domaine et doit simplement
la firme et cisèle mesures pour financer
justement l'allocation d'autonomie pour
les étudiants dont on parlait il ya
quelques minutes jean luc mélenchon veut
taxer beaucoup plus lourdement les
héritages les plus élevés dans le but
donc de réduire les inégalités il
souhaite notamment que pour ceux qui
héritent de plus de 12 millions d'euros
eh bien l'état prélève tout ce qui
dépasse 12 millions d'euros donc un 13e
et un 14e millions d'euros par exemple
alors cependant s'il mesure qui n'est
pas garantie de passer auprès du conseil
constitutionnel
l'instance donc chargé de vérifier que
les lois ne sont pas contraires à la
constitution c'était une mesure
importante de jean luc mélenchon dans
son programme il veut faire passer l'âge
de la retraite à taux plein à 60 ans
autrement dit plus tôt qu'aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui la règle générale c'est
qu'il faut attendre 65 ans pour avoir
une retraite à taux plein donc une
retraite avec le montant maximum
possible même si en soit on peut partir
aujourd'hui des soixante deux ans sous
certaines conditions mais donc voilà
jean luc mélenchon veut désormais la
retraite à 60 ans à taux plein mais
l'enfant veut aussi réduire le nombre
d'années de travail pour certaines
personnes dont le travail est pénible
par exemple les travailleurs de nuit qui
pourrait arrêter de travailler après 32
ans d'activité c'est ce que propose
d'ailleurs aussi notamment fabien
roussel aujourd'hui pour la
présidentielle pour votre information
aujourd'hui ils peuvent partir un peu
plus tôt que les autres employés qui
bossent pas de nuit mais c'est calculé
au cas par cas donc je peux pas vraiment
vous donner de chiffres générés là
dessus 7e mesure de jean luc mélenchon
qui est centrale dans son programme
d'ailleurs peut-être qu'on aurait dû
commencer par cette mesure celle en vie
si jean luc mélenchon de mettre fin à la
cinquième république donc le régime
politique actuel en france pour passer à
la 6ème république c'est vraiment le
seul candidat en parlait autant et c'est
un point important de sa candidature en
gros jean luc mélenchon considère que la
république tel quel et donne trop de
pouvoir au président que si elles
manquent parfois de transparence que les
citoyens n'ont pas assez de pouvoir et
donc concrètement il propose de changer
le fonctionnement des différentes
institutions de la république
l'assemblée nationale le sénat le rôle
du président encore le rôle du prêt
ministre c'est des rôles aujourd'hui
qu'ils sont définis par la constitution
jean luc mélenchon propose donc une
assemblée constituante donc un ensemble
de citoyens rédigent une nouvelle
constitution qui donnerait plus de
pouvoir à l'assemblée notamment et moins
de pouvoirs au président de la
république ce nouveau texte serait
ensuite adopté par référendum donc tous
les citoyens seraient appelés à voter
pour dire si oui ou non l'acceptent et
ses amis de l'accepter bien cette
nouvelle constitution serait mise en
place et on passerait ainsi à la 6ème
république autre sujet maintenant la
question de la police selon lui la
population n'a plus confiance dans la
police et inversement la police se méfie
trop de la population il souhaite
notamment démanteler la brigade
anticriminalité la bac donc qui est
spécialisée dans les interventions en
zone sensible pour la remplacer par une
police de proximité donc plus
spécialisés par zone et qui serait plus
proche d'une certaine façon de la
population il souhaite aussi changer les
méthodes de travail de la police dans
certains cas en interdisant certaines
méthodes qu'il juge trop violente
aujourd'hui dernier point à
l'international jean luc mélenchon
souhaite changer les traités européens
tels qu'ils sont actuellement pour
qu'ils soient en accord avec son
programme avec par exemple plus de
protectionnisme écologique concrètement
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
que c'est bien jean luc mélenchon
souhaite favoriser les produits qui sont
fabriqués en france par exemple en
taxant les produits qui viennent
d'ailleurs ou alors en donnant des
subventions aux productions françaises
qui sont respectueuses de
l'environnement
par contre c'est pas sûr qu'ils arrivent
à renégocier ses traités en tout cas
c'est un vrai défi pour lui puisqu'il
faudrait que tous les pays de l'union
européenne soit d'accord du coup ça mais
ils n'arrivent pas à re négocier ces
traités européens il propose que la
france arrête de participer à certains
programmes européens quitte à payer du
coup des amendes voilà donc pour les dix
mesures majeures après comme pour les
autres candidats je vous mets des liens
en descriptions et là je vais vous
présenter en vrac quelques mesures en
plus qui me paraissent importantes a
mentionné au moins jeunes avec mélenchon
veut quitter l'otan donc l'organisation
militaire dont fait partie aujourd'hui
la france avec les états unis et
plusieurs pays européens
il veut aussi à mettre en place un
budget d'un milliard d'euros pour lutter
contre le sexisme et contre les
violences faites aux femmes il souhaite
que l'allocation adulte handicapé soit
indépendante des revenus du conjoint
autre mesure jean luc mélenchon veut
légaliser le cannabis il veut mettre fin
au passage vaccinale il parle également
d'abaisser le droit de vote à 16 ans
contre 18 ans aujourd'hui jean luc
mélenchon souhaite également que l'état
reprenne le contrôle de plusieurs
secteurs clés de l'économie c'est
notamment les aéroports la française des
jeux ou encore les autoroutes et enfin
jean luc mélenchon souhaite notamment
pouvoir bloquer les prix des produits de
première nécessité voilà donc pour les
mesures principales de jean luc
mélenchon vous le disait sur sa chaîne
youtube dans les prochains jours on va
vous présenter le programme de tous les
candidats on va aussi interviewé les
candidats à l'élection présidentielle
avec un nouveau format du coup n'hésitez
pas à vous abonner ce n'est pas encore
le cas pour ne pas louper les vidéo
suivante et découvrir aussi pourquoi pas
les autres vidéos rendez-vous aussi sur
instagram pour découvrir d'autres
contenus au quotidien et suivre cette
présidentielle avec nos connaissances
vous prenez soin de vos proches et on se
dit du coup a très vite